[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up dallas
[Applause]
look at you guys
i'm not used to this dallas a little
different there's some ladies in the
crowd tonight
i am not used to that
my demo 18 to 36 bros that's
that's what i specialize in
it's a real cockfest usually at these
things
i don't mind it though i'm the bro
whisperer that's what they call me
are we vaccinated up in here dallas
everybody vaccinated
[Applause]
dicey nice dude
i love you texas that's how it is
i love it
there's always one guy no [ __ ] way
bro
that needle's not touching this [ __ ]
temple daddy
as he says that he's taking a nacho
dipping nacho cheese
oh my batmister whole foods my bad
yeah whatever you want to do man i just
this whole vaccination stuff i'm not an
anti-vaccine i'm vaccinated but it's uh
it's all in their marketing they [ __ ]
this whole thing up in their marketing
without operation warp speed when they
launched that remember they're trying to
get everybody get vaccinated and they're
like yeah go to krispy kreme buy a dozen
donuts get vaccinated
the
like
that makes sense
that people are like hell yeah [ __ ] this
it was so confusing
i called my mom i was like hey mama are
you uh are you getting vaccinated she's
all i wasn't and then you know i love
donuts
the rumor of the first dumbass that
messed it all up for everybody scared
the [ __ ] out of from getting vaccinated
remember that idiot he's all over the
news stations the first [ __ ] to get
that johnson and johnson clearly a meth
addict they just
nobody checked into his background
remember that they put him on the news
he's sweaty as [ __ ] he's on all the
major broadcasts he's like holy [ __ ]
dude
yeah i got it done i got that johnson
johnson bro i don't feel good bro
i can't stop sweating bro
i feel like i'm going wings
i'm gonna i'm gonna lay low for a little
bit on the vaccination i'm just gonna
remember that [ __ ]
it's all in marketing man like they need
to hire some just a dime piece actor
we've never heard of just blast them all
over the news right just somebody who's
fine get them on there
and just put them all over the news all
over the nation like yeah dude i get the
johnson johnson i feel pretty good i
feel great actually if i'm being honest
one side effect if i just want to be up
front everybody goddamn dicks down to
here
you'd have a line of bros at cvs just
like
trying to do my part man
it's good to be in dallas man you guys
do it right it's good to be in dallas i
know
yeah
yeah
there's a reason i shoot my special here
man you guys just give me so much love i
absolutely love texas man i
uh yeah thank you thank you
i uh i haven't touched a mass since i
touched down it is fantastic
la is not like this y'all
la is north korea with a beach
but they give us wi-fi so that's cool
they're talking about locking us back
down i can't go through it on a lockdown
straight up my the shop household barely
made it through the last one we eat our
way of that last one we did not do well
with it also dallas my lockdown is damn
friend i got a five-year-old
two-year-old parents know what i'm
talking about i would rather do anything
else than be locked down with those
[ __ ] demons 24 7.
we're not even locked down my girl was
fighting with me the other week we are
locked down we're [ __ ] she was
fighting with me [ __ ] a faulty ninja
delta ninja mask what are we gonna do
minion you'll see myself oh my god my
life would be so much easier if i was
just gay as [ __ ]
if i was locked down with the bros
dallas
quarantine with the homies you know how
much more fun we would have oh my god
dude
we'd like play video games all day
we'd work out
at night we'd [ __ ] each other
[Applause]
this guy was all the [ __ ] no i
thought we're gonna play video games bro
i'm sorry man
i love that
no [ __ ] no i'm not into that dude i'm
not
i don't be locked down with you anymore
i just
what are you gonna do row you're bored
[Laughter]
one can dream dallas one can dream
i never thought i'd say this to a live
audience one thing that i'm grateful for
for the the governor of california
governor newsom for locking us down for
entire year and ruining small businesses
because i wouldn't have realized this
unless i was locked down with my family
for an entire year
i realized my girl's not cool she's just
not
she's not a friendly human being i uh
i married a goddamn rattlesnake
this is my girl this is my girl man this
is what i'm dealing with yo
listen la's different than texas mike
they just opened my son's school last
week he hasn't been school in a [ __ ]
year they just opened it last week first
day of kindergarten so i got him his
first day outfit looking all [ __ ] fly
dope kicks giant backpack backwards hat
looks just like me i'm walking up for
school i'm like dude it's about to be
lit as [ __ ]
all those little friends out front in
the first day outfits i'm like oh my god
you guys are cute as [ __ ] i need to
document this aot get tight there's a
bunch of you squeezing tight daddy's
gonna take a picture ready cheese on
three ready one two three cheese they're
all cheese i take out my phone i'm all
hell yeah
i snap a pic i text it to my girl she
gets it she looks at she goes
crop out the uglies resend
what
excuse me
i said you're in a group chat to other
parents dumbass
[Applause]
savage all savage
i married a mexican y'all i married a
mexican
[Music]
i thought you would like that listen
listen that listen i thought you guys
would enjoy that listen dallas dallas i
don't mean like taco bell mexican no no
no no i'm talking guadalajara
born and raised came to the states 10
years ago illegally mexican
[Applause]
the real deal holyfield y'all this [ __ ]
is
i did a lot of white girls big titties
and flat asses before her it just never
worked out for me it just would never
work out and i don't forget this one my
boys goes dude dude papi what are you
doing bro
get with a latina bro you know why cause
they're fun and they're spicy
no doubt definitely spicy grilled spicy
right girl spicy you know what spicy
means they're [ __ ] that's what that
means
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry man
dude when we first got together she was
cooking authentic mexican food seven
nights a week i'm not used to this i was
like what fajitas every wednesday [ __ ]
yeah
no dumbass stop the heaters every
wednesday real mexican dishes y'all real
[ __ ] from the motherland i'm talking
huevos rancheros
carnessa
my favorite chili ah
every night though every night seven
years later every [ __ ] night i know i
look latin there's gonna know who i am
she's like honey what the [ __ ] is
happening right now
is he not a puerto rican shortstop for
the dodgers what the [ __ ] happening
dude i did that 23andme i did that [ __ ]
you spin the cup email your dna in i did
that they sent me drive mayonnaise back
i am white as [ __ ] dallas yeah
white person handout page seven [ __ ] i
need a [ __ ] tater tot once a week
would a [ __ ] hot pocket kill you
every now and then
every time dinner would come i'm like oh
does she really think beans go with
every goddamn meal she's serious
she for real
every time they would come like does it
ever occur to her maybe brendan's not
trying to [ __ ] his pants tonight how
about that
[ __ ]
every time dinner would come my [ __ ]
will go like this
[ __ ] bro
no
we're dying down here poppy
it's so spicy bro
i've never been thicker since i got with
a mexican man
think with three [ __ ] c's
dude everything they eat bean cheese
bean cheese bean cheese bean she's like
what the hell man we're gonna carb load
year round
we never tailor off the carbs that's the
game plan
which all can be built like armadillos
[Laughter]
i guess so thick in the pandemic i uh i
decided to go on a keto diet
if you know what keto is keto is a diet
where you can't eat mexican food that's
the diet
it's pretty easy to stick to man just
don't touch a [ __ ] tortilla you know
what i'm saying
here's my problem though here's my
problem every friday my mother-in-law
cooks my favorite mexican food at my
house she has her own house but does
that mind it makes no sense
so before i started this keto diet i
went up to my girl hey you know i love
your mom her food best in the world it's
my favorite that's why i'm so [ __ ]
fat listen
do me a favor though i don't want to be
tempted i don't want the house do me a
favor tell your mom on monquito can you
do that she goes why don't you tell her
she speaks english i went but she
doesn't though but she doesn't
you keep saying that she clearly [ __ ]
doesn't
do me a solid tell her my [ __ ] keto
okay
eight weeks goes by your boy hasn't
touched a [ __ ] tortilla nothing i
walked in the house last friday
sure enough there's a [ __ ] fiesta
and my favorite food
you know how like theo von can't brown
cocaine
now like he struggles with cocaine
like if there was cocaine on the table
right now he'd [ __ ] snort it from
right field you feel me
god bless him i love that [ __ ] dude
that's i iron with [ __ ] plasole i see
it dude i will [ __ ] take it to the
snout i can't be around it
i see it i eat it
so i walked in i go mama mama you know i
love mama what are you doing i know you
know i'm on keto i know i know you know
somebody told you a monkito she goes
miho miho bueno andale mio mio cabron
cabrone look kabron
lebron
she grabs this straight she goes cabron
cabron look taquitos
it's kino [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm just gonna stay thick y'all it's my
dna
oh the other thing you should know about
dana mexican nobody told me this there's
many flaming hot cheetos all over your
house
they love them they
love them
it's like catnip for mexicans they love
them
i'm the only person in my house who
don't speak spanish
i feel like a refugee in my own goddamn
house
my white friends aren't a latina before
i go dude just [ __ ] learn spanish put
a little effort in learn spanish how
hard can it be my [ __ ] i am 38
i struggle with english at times
you know what it feels like to my
five-year-old son roll up on his bike
and talk [ __ ] to me in spanish you know
what that feels like
as a father you know what that feels
like
i don't have a clue what he's talking
about i have a clue
i thought punto met dude for the longest
time
i dropped another school last week i was
all later punto
teacher was like what the [ __ ] am i
putto pluto
well the many things i love about the
mexican culture is uh i and i do love
your culture man well the many things i
love about it is you guys always have
something to celebrate
every week you have something to
celebrate
as a white person my dad's like only
your birthday [ __ ]
all right once a year be cool dad be
cool
not mexicans every week something's
popping
last week some girl turned 15.
[Applause]
not not even related to us
through the party at my house
apparently the mexican culture turned 15
is a big deal
white people we don't give a [ __ ]
these mexicans gave all the [ __ ] yeah
i walk in the house these mexicans give
a [ __ ] about social distancing there was
a mask in sight i walk in the house
there's a mariachi band
they're beating the shadows pinata
there's flaming hot cheetos spraying
over the goddamn living room
i walk in i like my girl jesus christ
quite the party
what are we celebrating once she getting
to harvard early what's going on here
she goes nope just turned 15 i went
[ __ ] yeah that makes sense
the other thing i love about the mexican
culture is you guys stick together you
guys are so loyal to each other you
[ __ ] have each other's back and i
love that white people we're not like
that are we
as soon as we turn 16 we're all [ __ ]
see it peter and dad being [ __ ]
those are my real parent names
i told you i'm white as [ __ ] man
yeah mexicans stick together like you
never walk in a bar and see one mexican
hammered by themselves no way
they're there with their amigos
i was taking my family out for dinner
the other night my family i mean all 15
of them
[Music]
and we walk outside and they'll gather
on my car i don't have a two-door coupe
it makes no [ __ ] sense
and my mother-in-law's at the trunk i'm
all right
mama we just talked about this inside
the house remember you have your own car
i will text you address we will meet at
the restaurant she goes nomiho
we fit
the [ __ ]
no you don't fit
she goes bueno we fit i went
please don't do this i promise you you
do not [ __ ] fit
sure enough we fit y'all we [ __ ] fit
man yeah
crazy yeah
two of them are hanging off the spoiler
didn't give a [ __ ]
[Applause]
forget how i'm gonna wrap up this
mexican bait going hard on my family
oh i know me my girl we're not doing
well that's right we're not doing well
so she wanted to go to couples therapy
i'm like all right good luck find one in
the middle of pandemic
she found one man she [ __ ] found one
yeah two-star review but we're going so
we're driving a couple's therapy she's
crying just because she ran a flaming
hot cheetos
i'm crying just because my life
currently
and we pull up to
we blow up this brick building this
small brick building i've never seen
some [ __ ] like this small little brick
building we pull up to and this
therapist has her name plastered on the
side of the goddamn building giant red
neon letters just [ __ ]
it says dr rodriguez
i get out i'm like
well it's an away game for your boy
isn't it
[Applause]
we did not go in there dallas we did not
we're looking for dr robinson maybe dr
allen at this point you feel me
[Applause]
a home field advantage
i moved in a house recently moved in a
new house in l.a whenever you move in a
new house it's always weird but it's
even weirder in the middle of pandemic
so i move into the house my girl goes
papi papi i've seen the neighbors
they're pretty old they're pretty let's
play it safe they're probably covered
conscious once you just go over and
induce yourself right i'll pick some
mexican cookies and you go over them
like what the [ __ ] mexican cookie what
are you talking about it's like a
chocolate chip with sauce all over it
what are you talking about
[Applause]
like that's a terrible idea just i'll
take it i'll figure it out
so first night in the new house
everything's all good man everything all
good kids fall asleep girl fall asleep i
fall asleep all good
3am on the dot i'm woken up to
what the [ __ ] is helen outside whatever
next day i install the security stuff
cameras the ring stuff all that all that
stuff the doorbell all the ring security
stuff all good fall asleep that night
kids asleep girls asleep i fall asleep 3
a.m on the goddamn dot i'm woken up
again
there's a goddamn gargoyle outside my
window dude
well i don't know about this ring app
you download the app this entire
community of people just snitched on
each other
it's like takashi 69 made this happen
it's
fantastic
i scroll listen dude
i scroll that out for hours looking for
real crime i'm like come on dude
somebody [ __ ] kill somebody for god's
sakes
how much first 48 i watch i'm like we
got 48 hours bro let's get going here
man
what i didn't know is you can narrow it
down to your hood you literally narrow
it down right to your neighborhood it's
dope you can look narrow it right down
so i'm like ooh let's see what's popping
this new neighborhood of mine
[Music]
two doors down jerry goes hey man this
mountain lion ain't my goddamn dogs
somebody needs to do something jesus
christ
that is not good
diane right next door to me goes yeah i
used to be the [ __ ] cat lady not
anymore that mountain lion ripped my
goddamn cat's head off and ate all of
them
my kids saw it from the window we can't
sleep at night
somebody needs to do something like this
is not good
then david right next door to me david
goes yeah the same mountain lion stole
my amazon package
all right
dude but that gives me the idea i'm like
ooh i know how i'm gonna introduce
myself to the new neighbors i'm gonna
take care of this little kiddie prom for
them that's what i'm gonna do
this is gonna be easy work but i need to
buy a gun i need to go buy a gun i've
never listened dallas i've never owned a
gun never shot a gun played call of duty
twice i'll figure it out
so i go to my local la gun store again
i've never bought a gun i got so hustled
in there i got so bamboozled dude listen
i've never shot a gun i walked out with
an ar-15
like the red laser thing on top of it
i walked out with the zero dark 30 navy
seal night vision helmet
what
i was like dude 19 grand for all this
hell yeah bro [ __ ] yeah it's a steal bro
no i'll wear it out no i can see
everything dude that cat's [ __ ] bro
yeah i'll keep you posted
and i'll let you know man yeah thank you
dude killer deal
so i get home i'm listen i'm never going
to go i'm hyped up i'm loan the gun i
get my [ __ ] night vision i'm like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] dope dude in my
head i'm like right this is this i'm
envision this right that cat shows up at
3am every night right so i'll be
sleeping it's 3am it's late i'll be
sleeping right i'm here wow i'ma [ __ ]
pop out of bed right i'ma [ __ ] yeah
and then i always have my uggs bedside
right my uggs will be right there
be cool tom brady wears hugs so i
[ __ ]
i'll put i slide my uggs on right i'll
have my ar-15 like this i'm by zero dark
30 night vision like this my big dick's
right there still so i'm like
i don't know why i threw that in but be
cool so i'm [ __ ] here
she's so offended so i'm here right
so i'm hearing that catch i'm like round
like enough enough dude i'm gonna slide
that slide door open like yeah and every
video i've ever seen like online those
mountain lions have like those soft wet
black noses i'm gonna pump them right in
that goddamn nose [ __ ]
and then
i'm looking my ring camera and go world
star
your boys can go viral it's gonna be lit
as [ __ ] i can't wait man
is that next night right i'm pacing back
and forth my girl's like go to bed i'm
all shut up [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] here
[Laughter]
again i got my ugg boots on i get my
ar-15
i get my zero dark 30 night vision on
right
still got the big dick sorry i'm [ __ ]
here
i had i got to stick with it right so
i'm here
i'm basically i'm looking at the clock
it's all 250 i'm all pretty god this cat
shows up bro it's 2 59 my last day on
earth for you kitty
3 am hits i hear ram all show time
i slide that glass door open them all
yeah
here's the thing dallas i uh
i've never seen a mountain person before
in my head i was thinking like a small
type of bobcat type of thing right like
the gun's a little extreme i don't need
the navy seal night vision dude like you
can probably grab it by the scruff of
the neck and be like enough's enough
kitty
[Music]
well no dumbass it's a line of the
mountains dude it's [ __ ]
this thing was mufasa [ __ ]
it's like this mountain lion ate joe
rogan's trash this is [ __ ]
oh i panicked dude i bet i went oh [ __ ]
and i slammed the door
dude i threw my ar-15 like this
i [ __ ] threw my night vision i'm not
even left-handed i was like oh my god
so you have my ugg boots still got the
big dick not a big deal
sorry i uh
i got that ring app the next morning
like yo we got a mountain lion problem
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all need a girl
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
big boys
[Music]
you